first of all
um like Israeli and many people will not
agree with what I'm saying when they're
feeling system this is the potential is
the right thing uh when you coming to
some level of uh understanding and
personal relation they're very like us
what you see is what you get okay they
put it more politely they are less less
blunt than we are but they are very very
uh and and they are you know
talking in understatements they are
still things like breeds but but you can
build relations there I mean if somebody
say something that uh they appreciate
you you understand it's important
politeness
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
this episode is all about the
intersection of Israel India anything in
between after this episode I'm booking
my flight to Bangalore meet Benjamin
Grossman partner and the head of the
Indian legal practice and APM and Co
among the leading law firms in Israel
Benjamin deals with indo-israeli
transactions for more than 20 years and
has in-depth knowledge and insights
about the ways to develop business
relations with Indian counterparts
Benjamin has developed expertise in
transfer of Technology deals between
Israeli and Indian companies he also
holds a bscn engineering as well as an
MBA
[Music]
Benjamin Grossman welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
I'm great thank you for posting me I'm
just great thank you very very much for
being here you get to deal with a
different type of law than a lot of
different lawyers in Tech here you get
to deal with you're working a lot with
India it's a big part of your practice
and a big part of your world so I'd love
to to get to know you a little bit
better in your work how did you even get
introduced to India as the market that
you're that you're working with in the
intersection of India and Israel
okay so it takes about 20 plus years
back I've been requested to help to the
certain deal in India quite urgently
um now
I mean I got the notice of 20 pounds to
be on the plane
uh I've never been in India before that
another
thought to be in India before that wow
India was not in my destination list
um
but you know when it comes
what happened or why why did you have a
20 hour notice to be on a plane there
was there was some kind of a deal that
was stuck and somebody was which was
supposed to need it I had some personal
issues he has to come back to Israel
immediately and uh it says okay I took
the next flight to India it was not the
same India as we know today flights were
quite difficult uh it was a long journey
like 24 hours altogether in that
particular day and then I landed in
India and then it was 3 AM
uh in the middle of the night and then I
don't know why I cannot put the finger
exactly what happened but there was some
kind of energies in the air which uh
which allowed for the from the first
side okay uh India is a love story on
the third flight for me
um
and then you know it evolves I learned I
understand I don't understand anything
about India and I also understand it's
very very uh
interesting place
uh I've failed it at home because there
were many points in that time in the
altitude today which was very similar to
Israel in many aspects
actually it reminds me
um the Israel I was brought up
and then in the 70s people were humble
and very curious about Israel there was
there has been and it's it's still today
a very high level of appreciation
of Israel Israel Technologies all
capabilities and so on sometimes I
wouldn't feel it a little bit a little
overrated in India but I prefer to be
ovulated than underrated and and uh it
was very interesting in all aspects
personal uh cultural
professional and then since then I'm
visiting India quite often like between
once a month or twice a month wow I okay
acquired lots lots of friends there lots
of friends
um
and I love the place
so when you so did you transition your
practice or your your your client
primarily to be those that are working
with India how did you how did you you
know sort of combine your the personal
love that you've gotten to the place
with the professional side of of your
day-to-day work
you know I maybe I'm not quoting it uh
exactly but life is what happened to you
when you're making plans you never plan
to be in India but I seen that deal came
after deal I was working with the
defense industry which is the major
chunk of business then
uh and each time
a new interesting deal came with new
terms and conditions with new people on
the other side with new opportunities
with you uh sectors to learn
and I'm the I'm a curious guy I like to
learn new things and if you're curious
India it's so uh the Disneyland for U.S
people because you can you can never
grasp India it's always changing very
interesting all the time and
professionally I learned a lot because
the system is different from the system
Israel there's a lot to learn and if you
learn something today you must be
updated because tomorrow it will be
different
um lots of changes India is moving ahead
the second elephant is moving not so
slow but very determined the elephant
will get to his point
and uh it doesn't look as fast as the
horse but it's more determined than the
horse it will it will reach the point
and I learned to appreciate the
bureaucracy the regulation
all these things which without it India
would not exist or would not uh
successities now and and the opportunity
is huge so maybe it's some kind of a
blue ocean and combining these elegant
abilities in the huge actually the
infinite Indian market for us
I think that um
it's it's the Dreamland for every
technology guy I'm a technology guy in
my background I was the engineer for
many years so I like technology I like
to deal with technology I'm dealing a
lot with transfer of Technology
so I also understand what it was to be
emphasized what is more important what
is less important
um
and it's always fun to to use the things
that you learned in the past and to do
new things with that take me back maybe
to sort of that initial
relationship that you formed with the
place you know for people that aren't
necessarily you know gotten a chance to
really experience it personally
professionally well what is you know
sort of what is it that you fell in love
with in terms of the culture or the
Way businesses made the way people are
interacting what was it that was so
special for you
upon um like Israeli and many people
will not agree with what I'm saying when
they're feeling system is the right
thing uh when you coming to some level
of uh understanding and personal
relations they're very like us what you
see is what you get okay they put it
more politely they are less less blunt
than we are but they are very very uh
and and there are you know
um talking in understatements they are
still things like uh breeds but but you
can build relations there I mean if
somebody say something that uh they
appreciate you you understand it's
important politeness
so I feel very comfortable with that and
uh within the time and you learn to know
exactly what they mean and you feel very
comfortable because the most difficult
thing
to get in India is is no it's a negative
answer and then you have to understand
from the yes if it's really yes or it's
a maybe or it's a no
um and and
add that kind of communication because I
feel that uh
I feel confident with that and I feel
that once you feel confident you can
generate the business
uh yes the process is long and tedious
and sometimes it's uh going up and down
and so on and whenever you think that
you got to the to the end it's only the
beginning of the next stage like just
mostly it's the beginning of it's not
even the beginning of the end it's the
end of the beginning all the time to
close the deal in India within a week or
two or to within a month or two even
within the Euro so it's very difficult I
just tell you something that I met
somebody in a plan when we fly when we
visited India with the president
revelance I believe that was about six
years back and it says that they are now
opened in our mou and then the mou will
be out for
developing through TLT just thoughts of
Technology agreement and all this they
put a deadline of two months so I was
polite because I didn't know the guy
very very closely and says okay good
luck to you and I told myself something
maybe we'll have this small piece right
there I don't know what will happen
Purity will not be signed with two
months it's something you know it's not
a legitimate molecule of time
so you have to be patient an impatient
guy and this gives us some kind of an
advantage
um and again they love it you know each
place I'm coming to India people loves
the Israelis I'll just tell you a short
story
um
when I was working one of the defense
companies uh with we have to send the
team to place which was a little
problematic in the sense of personal
uh security and we have reported to the
police that
we are there so in the middle of the
night the chief of the position that
Village got plenty bigger than the
village come to the hotel and asked to
see the Israelis and we want them very
scared so he said that he heard that the
Israelis are the most clever people in
the world he never seen when he dies
they will squirt how he was sorry
so let's give you an understanding how
it's still there and again business-wise
I think this is the most the this is the
biggest opportunity we have now with you
know there are some recitations whether
to go with China to go with China India
is now positioning itself as a
superpower not as part of the brick
there is an independent superpower they
are playing very smartly in this Russian
U.S game
uh incredible a very smart politician
yes and they are diplomats and I really
feel like it's my second home fantastic
so um tell me a little bit about about
your day-to-day work well what is it
that you do in your day-to-day
well when we are dealing with the uh any
kind of transaction in India and we're
dealing with big volumes there are
certain pages that you have to go
through there are no shortcuts in India
if your shortcut you'll get to the two
one
quite immediately
uh sometimes not understand you think
that you're focusing but you are
climbing in the area not climbing the
ladder again uh so we're starting with
negotiation with understanding the
purpose of the deal the principles of
the deal the obstacles of the deal just
now we had a deal that I understand
after two minutes that there is some
effects issue that uh
damians were not staying in fact they
was not aware of the Israeli party was
not the way off we are thinking very
differently although we are speaking
both English the meaning of the English
is
totally different and then it says okay
guys but now we have a gap of 20 tax
that Spa is to be withheld in India how
we overcome that and then we
um
Untitled say the the notes okay little
by little we find a solution to that
then we understand about the label or in
Israel and the labor we are we are we
are resolving the issues one
one and then we are creating some kind
of a moo which puts in uh lighting the
all the principles
if you don't
um
record something in the end of the call
with some kind of email mou letter of
understanding whatever you call it it
does Adventure ways next time you did
the first first phrase and you want to
be in the in the next phase you have to
climb over there
the previous one which you have to
record in writing so recording there can
then it's like a puzzle okay then we are
going to the next stage and we are
making the things more concrete and the
mechanism payment so
consideration for example if you're
getting consideration for untangibles
it's a different person you want to see
the money it's a different from a
consideration that you get for uh other
for example totally different you know
the different kind of uh
authorizations from the Indian side it's
a total different story they're looking
at things differently not I want to give
you something some comment
I've always recommend to people not to
criticize age inside
the Indian fight song don't don't be
here don't criticize understand the
constraints the philosophy they are not
the left or smart than we are
the
things differently because they have a
different uh approach
or some different uh regulations to uh
to fulfill okay but don't criticize the
wisdom was not given only to us
interesting
at least it was very evenly shared
between two two parties sometimes it's
difficult with some Israeli interesting
something else I'll be very very thank
you just some of my job is also to keep
the Israel inside
modus and aware to the
to the advantage of the other side of
the of the oceans they are going or the
zombies we are doing it on Zoom
and the process is long you know
sometimes sometimes of these
negotiations can take like eight hours
you know in the in the coffee that was
spending I was working from home so uh I
would spend like eight hours
continuously in one Zoom call going out
did something incredible to the next one
uh that's it and you cannot avoid by the
end of the day you cannot avoid to come
and to see why do you think it's awesome
it's the the
because this is part of the culture then
they want to see with whom they are
dealing they want to shake your hands
they want to see
to smell your sweat I don't know but
they want to see the people it's they're
very uh human oriented incredible
even the biggest one and so when you're
looking at sort of the uh well one thing
that you that you said that that wasn't
particularly interesting to me was this
idea of keeping modesty keeping modest
and humble about what we may not know
that we don't know right and you were
talking about the nature of their
behavior the nature of their decision
making that they may even have different
goals to fulfill than the goals that we
would attribute based on what we have
right that was a big part of what you
mentioned
yes
yes and you know the most important
thing is to understand what you don't
understand or to know what you don't
know
uh the the goddess with the details is
something which is particularly true in
India and I'll tell you about myself I
believe that I can say I'm expert to
India after 20 years or 21 years and
still before each deal I'm refreshing my
knowledge and getting advice from some
of my colleagues in India if something
has been changed some of the policy has
been changed things like that because
we have to understand that we are not
understanding everything and it's not
that we can impose our uh terms on the
other side it's it's a very delicate
um
dialogue and negotiation
uh this may take times
it's it's a long process which you
cannot there are no shortcuts be patient
be smart be humble be kind and be
professional there is a to do deals in
India right it doesn't seem like many
entrepreneurs today still understand
India is a sort of this big opportunity
that you're describing it to be why why
is that
laughs
first of all I do see a Trends in which
there are more and more children and
startups which do devote some of their
energies to India much more than in the
past maybe because the Chinese market is
now more risky
I don't know but uh and mainly because
people like me and many other and some
other people in Israel
uh increase the awareness of the Indian
markets and also today the inner Market
is much more accessible than in the past
just to give you a
an idea in India today there are 47 000
startups
and they are talking about 90
000 wow 25 okay the ecosystem
is is boiling wow he's burning
uh that's two years back it was a few
thousand
uh go to Bungalow take it and see what's
going on how many wee walks there are
there right right I'm not talking about
the brand I mean uh uh for a common uh
walking place
it's because it's it's taking
um
big and bigger portion of the economy
and in that sense there are more
open-minded to work with usual
entrepreneurs and so there's a Good
Vibration from both sides
so I think the trend the trend is there
but you know to educate the market
always
take time
so most of your work is
most of your work is under intersection
of Israeli entrepreneurs in the Indian
market that that's where the bread and
butter of what you do
yes the 20th century from the Indian
sizes can be used upon us like to take
the adani deals from from last week
Mr adani is uh to have any soul
okay so entrepreneurs maintained their
soul as the nine cities entrepreneurs
are also huge
and still most of them are still kind
and moderate and humble and
such an experience in listening to your
you know your experience with India I
didn't expected us to talk about the
Indian ecosystem but not to such a
personal degree so I appreciate your
your candidness and uh and transparency
here it and it's just really cool to
hear how you're respecting their culture
their Ambitions their goals and um and
it's you know we hear a lot about how
the Indian ecosystem is growing but
you're really grounding it in the
conversation to the point where you know
I I need to plan my trip to Bangalore to
go and see what's happening and because
it sounds like it's a it's a must
I'll get I'll give some recommendations
about that exactly about the best
restaurants incredible is really my
second home Benjamin thank you so much
for everything stay safe stay healthy
and thank you for the time here
thank you forcing me thank you
thank you